la Commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme a remis ce matin à
Michel Rocard son rapport sur la lutte
contre le racisme ce document constitue
en France la première tentative
d'inventaire des différentes
manifestations de racisme constaté
durant l'année précédente l'année 90
conclusion globale de ce rapport le
nombre des agressions racistes est resté
stable mais la forte progression des
menaces ou des injures semble traduire
la banalisation d'un certain racisme
dans les mentalités analyse Florence
bouquilla
premier constat depuis 10 ans les
violences n'ont pas augmenté de façon
sensible mais en
1990 la police dénombre tout de même 52
agressions racistes dont 37 contre des
maghrébains un mort et 36 blessés et 20
de nature antisémite l'affaire de
Carpentra aura un effet boule de neige
dans les semaines suivantes 24 autres
tombes juives seront
profané parallèlement menaces et injures
en tout genre on doublé depuis 1988
selon la Commission des Droits de
l'Homme cette augmentation traduit une
dangereuse banalisation d'un certain
racisme dans les mentalités un racisme
d'ailleurs
ciblé en gros les communautés d'origine
magrbine qui pay le prix le plus lourd
au racisme et ensuite ce sont
effectivement les communautés d'origine
juive et puis vous avez un RAC très
spécifique très particulier en ce qui
concerne les gens du voyage premier
vecteur de ce racisme en France
l'extrême droite violente nommément cité
dans le rapport le Front national mais
aussi les mouvement activiste type PNFE
parti nationaliste français et
européens pour améliorer la prévention
du racisme cette étude propose deux
solutions parmi d'autres la médiation de
terrain pour désamorcer les conflits de
proximité et la mise en place à titre
expérimental de cellulle départementales
de lutte contre le
racisme